how [ __ ] dare you sorry i got really
winning on youtube i just got a little
charged up that [ __ ] got me
is anybody here happily in a
relationship willing to claim each other
you too
good for you and where the [ __ ] were you
at clapping miss
i said who's happily in a relationship
this [ __ ] didn't even think
twice
i was looking at you he clapped at woo
and then she had nothing to [ __ ] say
right behind him
you built her a fence for no reason huh
she's trying to put you on the other
side of that [ __ ]
[Applause]
hey just go outside build some [ __ ] i
don't need a look at your goddamn face
for the rest of the day
who knows they're offense do you all
live together yeah i'm
married
that's a good man dude you got a good
man i hope you appreciate that's a good
man
yeah you better
this guy's [ __ ] exhausted that's what
it is to be a good man you are
constantly tired you're not tired this
[ __ ] is
built her offense and i guarantee you
she's all happy today and thankful
and then next week if they don't go
anywhere she's going to be like we
didn't go anywhere for an entire week
and you'd be like [ __ ] i took you
somewhere after i built a [ __ ] fence
you know beyonce saying that
irreplaceable song you're not
irreplaceable dog
there's not a lot of [ __ ] dudes out
here building fences look at me you
think i built a fence
the more i talk to him the more i think
he should be allowed to cheat on you
real talk
real talk this is a guy that should be
allowed to cheat
he listen he probably wouldn't do it
anyway because he's just such a
sweetheart but if he is so
tempted you're not replacing no
[ __ ] like this
i got i know right you're building
fences
what do you do for a living can i ask
you that illegal stuff
legal stuff you're a lawyer who builds
fences i'll [ __ ] you buddy what are you
talking about
are you out of your goddamn mind i can't
do better a lawyer who's just building
[ __ ]
that's a man who makes money that's
crazy you a goddamn
catch i did not see that coming man with
that simp ass the way you clapped when
i asked who's in a relationship what a
guy dude
listen if my girl was like you can't
cheat on me i'd be like you're right
but if you ever told him to be faithful
i'd be like how dare you
how [ __ ] dare you
you guys you guys getting fights a lot
me and my girl be getting in fights but
i want to know about you guys
yeah yeah i i dislike her man right now
how dare you fight with this guy
this is a good man i know fence color
are you out of your goddamn mind yo are
you out of your
[ __ ] mind you know hey i'm mad i got
just now
i gotta i was like oh i'm starting to
look crazy i need to back up a little
bit because i was
how did you see are you out of your
[ __ ] i was like ready to charge up
here
and be like you crazy that bothered me
on a deep level you didn't like the
fence color you didn't know beforehand
i'm so upset right now dawg
sorry i got really winning on youtube i
just got a little charged up that [ __ ]
got me
i just never melted i've never met a man
in the north who builds fences
and then gets yelled at because the
color wasn't right what
i got it again i'm in it again what
color was this fence
lona brown huh conan brown cona brown a
brown fence what's wrong with a brown
fence
conan brown he said kind of like you
ah man
[Applause]
hey somebody look up corner brown and
let me know if he's accurate or not
cause i can't
i can't tell if it's like a not funny
kind of racist joke or if the man just
knows his colors i don't know
you know what i mean now you guys know
what conan brown is you could act like
his racist but you ain't looked it up
[Music]
[Music]
you